what up guys welcome to the BART Juan
quick and nasty cooking show and it's
quick and nasty not because the food's
nasty it's because I'm trying to make
something quick and the video is gonna
be quick so I'm here for lunch and one
of my favorite things to do when I'm
cooking is putting what kind of
leftovers do we have with what other
type of ingredients do we have and
making something that is kind of hearty
so the main source of inspiration for me
today is we actually have a ton of
ground beef
so we made so much this is just one of
the buckets so we have another one
over here look at this we have a ton of
ground beef and I love having super lean
cooked ground beef ready to go because
it's easy to season you can make in
Asian you can make it Mexican like make
tacos you can make all kinds of stuff
with it but since I've been on a diet
the thing that I'm missing is a deep
hearty flavor
so I was looking around like what do we
got I look in our pantry
and look at this bam we got a big old
thing of beef broth
and I was like okay okay
and then we got some mushrooms Bubba bam
and then some carrots but the BAM and
onions and I was like I can make some
sort of like beef stew
which is deep in flavor right
and then I can mix that with this meat
into some rice
because I always got rice on standby
that we made yesterday look at that
so that I can have like a deep hearty
stew that has all those ingredients so
that's what I'm gonna do for lunch and
what I also like about making like a
beef broth type thing it's easy to store
I can just put it in the fridge put it
away later and also it's a balanced meal
we got the meat already over there and
then we also got a ton of veggies so
when taika comes home and eats it I'll
feel very comfy that he's getting
carrots onions garlic and mushrooms all
up in there I'm actually a little bit
sad because I bought these uh heirloom
carrots and I wanted to show taika
because I feel like you'd get a kick out
of some carrots in different colors so I
didn't want to cut until you came home
but
what can you do it's time to cook and uh
I can't wait for them because I am
starving
so first thing I did is chop up all
these carrots
and I try to make them a little bit
thinner so it doesn't take as long uh to
boil and what I noticed is some of these
onions have been staying or sitting in
our fridge for a long time like this had
a little bit of mold on it so I just cut
it off the rest of it
smells cool so you know Asian style we
don't let anything go to waste so I'll
chop up these onions chop up this garlic
I always get peeled garlic because it's
way way easier and then chop up maybe
half of these mushrooms and I'll throw
it in the pan saute it around and add
some beef broth
dude look how hearty this looks already
we got the carrots
got some smashed garlic
got a handful of mushrooms and twice the
amount of onions I love onions I think
onions bring out the flavor of beef like
crazy so I packed it with onions and so
do mushrooms now I'm gonna
saute this with the garlic
and a pot just for a little bit just to
bring out the flavor
and then I'll pour in the beef stock
[Music]
since I'm on a diet well both me and Geo
are on a diet now
um I always use non-fat cooking spray
otherwise I would love to use some olive
oil because then you can get like a
deeper color and it just Cooks better
but this will have to do
I got the pot picked out it's a big old
pie spray some olive oil up in here and
you can see it's smoking right away
because I've already heated the pot
first things first
throw on these onions
oh
this is gonna be hard to do with one
hand I'm gonna throw the onions and the
garlic in and I'll show you what it
looks like
all right so I got the onions and the
garlic in place
I'm gonna mix them around a little bit
it already smells good
no it's all good already
probably after a few minutes just when I
start to see it to like just uh
slightly Brown I'll throw the mushrooms
in and give those a little stir fry just
like to bring out the flavor
right so you see how it's looking kind
of clear
right when it's about to be clear it's a
good time to season it
throw in a little bit of garlic salt
around
then
I'm not throwing these mushrooms
[Music]
get all that flavor going
all right you guys need to see how good
this looks this looks so good it's just
onions garlic and mushrooms look look at
that
[Music]
mixing all that flavor around
a nice little mix
on a little bit
all right one more time to Corn the
broth
first things first when you have
something in the pantry you gotta check
the expiration date because if you're
like me sometimes you have something
from like 20 20. okay cool not until the
end of this year
good
now pour in this broth okay
oh yeah
oh yeah look at all of that
the whole thing in there
this will probably honestly
make for so two meals for lunch me and
Geo probably another three meals for me
geother so I'll probably come out to
five meals which is cool so once we got
these guys up in here
mix it around
time to put in the carrots
and then I'm gonna bring it to a boil
and then I'll let it sit on medium
for probably a good 10 minutes because
carrots are kind of hard to cook and you
want to bring all the flavor all
together
and then I'm a taste test to see what
else I need to do to season it
so while I'm waiting for it to boil
I'm one of those guys that likes to
clean the kitchen as I'm going so that
way when you're done you don't have one
giant mess you have to clean because the
last thing you want is you cook bomb
food you eat you have a good time you
look over to the kitchen you're like ah
damn it so I'm already gonna move all
this stuff over
so by the time I that's ready to boil
the kitchen is also clean
[Music]
all right let's check up on this see if
it's at a boil
actually smells really good already okay
put it on medium
and then hey Google
10 minute timer
sure 10 minutes and that's starting now
so if you weren't on a diet you could
put some fancy stuff in there to make it
really really good like red wine make a
red wine reduction or you could add some
cornstarch or a thickening agent so it
gets really really hearty almost like
the inside of a chicken pot pie but I'm
on a diet so I have to stick with what I
can I'm trying to keep the calories as
low as possible the cool thing is with
veggies they're generally almost no
calories like carrots
mushrooms onions all that stuff
everything in here is probably like in
one bowl is probably under 10 calories
most of it being just fiber so that's
what's really cool but it creates a deep
flavor so that I can add to the ground
beef and my rice mix so just letting
this cook for a little bit I already
cleaned the
um the cutting boards
and you can see that the kitchen is
ready to go
so me and Mom are on very very similar
diets with just me having way more
protein so both of us only need half a
cup of rice
so I waited out which is uh just about
70 grams
and she's gonna have six grams of cooked
ground beef well I will need nine
because uh cooked ground beef I think
has like a 0.75 ratio so six grams
cooked is pretty much uh eight grams
uncooked so if I get nine it's just math
I believe that's 12. grams uncooked
because I need higher protein so I try
to get like anywhere from 60 to 80 grams
of protein per meal and how I like to do
is is I'll put this in here cover it
with a paper towel heat up in the
microwave because this doesn't really
need to be cooked it's already cooked
and then when the broth is done I just
pour it over and mix it all up
so this is the difference between me and
my bear she got six ounces nine ounces
but both of us have half a cup of rice
which is about 70 grams
and this is what I do to heat it up I
put a wet paper towel on top so it
retains the moisture
kind of open up the microwave
put this bad boy in
and I give it a good
two minutes bam
all right in five four three two three
okay hey Google stop
that means it's time
it's a taste test
if I could find that utensil up right
here it is
and she's ready to taste test too aren't
you a young lady
all right let me turn off the uh
vent because we don't need that anymore
and turn it on a low
I'm excited
look at that
all right
I'm actually nervous and excited at the
same time because I just freestyled
everything so I've never really tasted
I'm about to taste it right now
I'm gonna taste it okay okay all right
so let's see okay
let's see let's try the little broths a
little bit
what the
foreign
that's pretty good
that's pretty good I mean that's it
I mean my freaking
Perfection ocds makes me want to add
stuff but that's usually what gets me in
trouble because it makes it too salty so
that is perfect I'm Gonna Leave it just
like that and then now I'll show you how
I serve it
all right so we got the meat and the
rice from out of the microwave
now mix it up a little bit so it's nice
and even
get some of the veggies throw it on top
and then get the soup
pour it there on the rice some more of
the soup put it on
the meat give a little more veggies
waiters are what is it oh carrots tyco's
gonna love that I know it's like a less
carrots that's I was so excited I was
like oh man but then too bad you can't
see it all right anyways what do you
mean he's gonna eat some when he gets
home now no I wanted him to see like in
the full song
I did I say the half of it but anyways I
love them so mix it all up like that
she's like please drop something please
drop something is this food for me
don't mix it all up like you get that
like typical fashion I don't try the
final product because I'm a little chef
bonjour the chef tries the final product
that you keep
your kid now when you're married
all right and and yeah but let me guess
it's scolding hot and you want me to
taste test it right now you said you
like hot stuff you literally take hot
showers you gotta be consistent you
can't be inconsistent flip-flopping like
that no no what are you it's a gradual
what are you what are you doing I go
slow it starts off the water's not
scalding because it'll make it slow go
like this slow to your face okay now try
some
hot
you said you were cold today I'll tell
you where the sweater did I say I was
cool today no I made it up
what do you think Mia is it gonna be
good
anything's good
I'm scared
this is Hardy it tastes really good yeah
yay it's really good
especially for this weather it's [__]
cold hell yeah
43 degrees it's perfect for this yeah
his diet friendly how much did you give
me six six ounces of uh 96 for ground
beef half a cup of rice and you got a
ton of veggies for your digestive track
because we all know you got some
digestive problems
do I uh you got IBS don't you do what oh
you got some sub something yeah just fat
hater blockers oh anytime I eat
something too rich and fatty
fatty so that's it for the quick and
nasty diet friendly beef stew go try it
out let me know if you like it like I
said I just grabbed a bunch of random
ingredients that we had threw it all
together
um if there's anything else I should add
to still keep it diet friendly let me
know I love collaborating and learning
from how other people like to season
stuff and until next time peace